- Opportunity.
- Opportunities.
- I went and created
opportunity for myself.
- Hello Believe Nation, my
name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve all
of the worlds major problems.
So, to help you in your journey today,
we're going to learn how you
cannot miss opportunities.
And as always, as your watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(inspiring orchestra music)
- Many of you have a
very small opportunity
and you're not taking
advantage of that opportunity
because you're not thinking
about the next opportunity.
You're looking at this as small.
No, this is the gateway.
Like, this is the first one, right?
So, you got to ask yourself
this question, like,
how do you keep that fire?
You know how you keep it?
You keep putting different
opportunities in front of you.
You keep setting different opportunities.
Anybody know who this is?
Yeah, you should.
He in the Big 10.
He gave us the business.
You should know who he is.
Yogi Ferrell.
Didn't get drafted.
Didn't' get drafted to the NBA.
Didn't get drafted but they just,
something happened the other day.
The Dallas Mavericks needed a player.
They gave my man a 10-day contract.
How much did he make?
They gave my man $100,000 dollars.
How much LeBron making?
A million!
They gave my man,
"Look for 10 days, we just
want you to play for us.
"Somebody got hurt.
"We are going to bring
you in for 10 days."
You know say, you got 10-days.
Ride the bench.
You know, do your thing,
but you only got 10 days.
Don't get your hopes up.
My man, be coming in,
I'm talkin' about Trick.
Boom.
No only three pointers like daggers.
Two seconds.
Boom.
The 10-day contract,
they turnin' this boy
about to get a contract.
What are you doing with your opportunity?
We all get one.
We all get the 10-day contract.
But, the question is,
will that 10-day contract
turn into a year contract?
Will it turn into a two year contract?
You think Yogi Ferrell is the only one
who's got the opportunity to come
from a developmental league and play?
Nope.
You think other people
doing what he doing?
Nope. Why?
Because they weren't prepared for it.
What are you doing in the dark?
When nobody's watching?
10-day contract!
But, he didn't come in and
say, "I only got 10 days."
That's what some of ya'll on.
Oh, since I only got 10
days, I might as well
only give 10 days worth of effort.
I might as well only give
10 days worth of energy.
Yogi Ferrell was like,
"I'm about to act like
this might be my last shot.
"I'm about to act like I'm starting.
"I'm about to act like LeBron.
"I'm about to act like Kyrie.
"I'm about to act like Steph Curry.
"When you put me in the
game, I'm tellin' you,
"I'm about to murder 'em."
And at the 10-day, he's
been murderin' 'em.
He's been on ESPN almost every day.
All they talk about, Yogi Ferrell.
I'm talking about NBA
TV, ESPN One, ESPN Two
like Spanish ESPN!
So, ya'll got to understand something.
What was Yogi doing before?
What was Yogi doing before he
got that opportunity, ya'll?
He was preparing for it.
You don't get in the game
and score like he scored.
So, he said, "So what I
didn't make the league.
"So what?
"They can't stop me from practicing.
"They can't stop me from
getting up in the morning
"and running drills."
So, the problem with most of you is,
you have an opportunity.
You wrote it down.
You wrote it down right here.
Opportunity.
They gave me an opportunity.
They gave me a shot.
Somebody gave me a GED.
I turned that GED into a four-year degree.
Somebody gave me a four-year degree.
I turned it into a Master's degree.
Somebody gave me a Master's degree.
I turned it into a PhD.
You got the opportunity,
what you doing with it?
Opportunity is coming.
Will you be ready when it comes?
- What if I offered you
1.25 million dollars
to sell the whole company?
- Mark, you're saying
screw the other sharks.
- Yep.
I like what you guys are doing.
I want you to come back
to me with a percentage.
I don't want you to
even talk to these guys.
- You're asking him to
take that option with you
right now and ignore us?
- Yep.
- You're not a very nice guy.
- It's not about me being wonderful
- No, no, I have that title, thank you.
- It's about making a
business decision, right?
- Hi, I'm Mark Cuban,
I'm a bully, look at me.
- What's that about, Mark?
- Like I said, guys,
you got to pay to play.
- There's tension in this room.
I can feel it.
- It's offensive.
- You got a shot here, right?
Don't let these guys drag you down.
- Are you really interested in this?
- I like the idea.
- You really think cooking
bacon bedside is a good idea?
- I love your passion.
I love your knowledge.
- I'm waiting for the but.
- Yeah, there's a but coming.
- You got a 24 second shot,
Clark, 750,000 dollars.
- I've never seen greed like that.
That's unbelievable greed.
- You broke up with your potential partner
without even looking at him.
- You're a savage.
- I'm just a lean, mean
shark machine, Baby!
If I say yes to whatever your counter is,
you have to tell me that
you will say yes immediately
and we have deal.
- 100,000 dollars
- Wait a minute.
- For 20% equity.
- Argh!
- Done, done and done.
- Crap!
- Did you like that, Barbara?
- I don't like it one bit.
(sharks laughing)
That was so damn smart.
- No but, that's a compliment to you.
- Barbara, I screwed you,
but it's a compliment to you.
- I feel really good about it.
- For every problem,
the problem itself presents an opportunity
that dwarfs the problem.
And that is to say, that
if I had only looked
at my failure with the audio book
and viewed it as a failure
in the product, let's say,
and not in the process,
I wouldn't have taken away much.
Instead, I realized that
my approach wasn't right.
Fixed my approach and that has led
to a lot of great successes.
- Success is born out of luck.
It's awareness of mind that take advantage
of that opportunity.
You will all become
fronted with opportunity.
You must take advantage of it.
Because If you don't take
advantage of your opportunity
you'll never realize your dreams.
Whether you want them or
not is the irrelevance.
You don't know that until you achieve it.
- I grew up watching movies
and imagining myself on screen.
So, aside from the very
serious things that I do,
I will occasionally do a
Snakes On A Plane because,
(audience laughing)
those are the kinds of movies
I like when I was a kid.
I always wanted to see myself in a movie
with a bunch of snakes.
And I'm still trying to
find the right slasher
movie to do because,
I like slasher movies.
And I'm still, I did
things like Deep Blue Sea
because I wanted to run from
something that had big teeth.
And all that kind of stuff.
So, I'm not that serious about it.
You know, I really think
movies should be fun and
I think they should be entertaining.
If I want to teach you something,
I'll do a documentary
but, I do this because
it feeds me.
It feeds my artistic sense.
A lot of people think
I do too many movies.
I read an article on
PBS today about me doing
too many movies but,
you know, writers get up
and write everyday.
Painters get up and paint everyday.
Actors only have so many
acting opportunities
in a life time.
I'm going to take mine as they come and
do as many movies as I can
before I'm up out of here.
- I remember two years ago
when the producer offer
me to play the bad guy, the villain.
Little red man for and I say,
"Oh, I made 25 movies in Hong Kong.
"I never play the villain so, I don't know
"my audience, what's their reaction when
"they heard the news."
Said, "Don't worry, here is the good guy."
He offer another movie, Romeo Must Die.
So, one bad guy, one good guy.
You can work. You have special skill.
You can make money for the studio.
Now in the future, right now,
maybe better than before.
I have a little bit of chance, can chose,
what kind of story I really want to make.
I hope in the future I
have more chance to chose
what kind of story I really want to make,
what kind of story I don't want to make.
- We'd only been on the, 32, I think
we hadn't even done 50 shows.
- Wow
- And so, I called Jon Stewart and I said,
"John, I just got invited for
the correspondence dinner.
"Do you think should do it?"
and he said, "What? Like to attend?"
and I said, "No, they want me."
He goes, "They want you to be the guy?"
(laughter)
"Like to stand next to the President?
Do they know what you do?"
and I said, "I don't know."
and I said, "I think I have to do it."
He goes, "You have to do it."
- You have to do it.
- Like, right now,
you have to do it.
So, don't pay attention
to the approval ratings
that say that 68 percent of American's
disapprove of the job this man is doing.
I ask you this, does that
not also logically mean
that 68 percent approve
of the job he's not doing?
(audience laughter)
Think about it.
I haven't
- You know, each day
looks very, very different
and truthfully that's part of
what I'm so passionate about.
I think more than being a developer,
more than having my own fashion brands,
I think of myself as an
entrepreneur who keeps
my eye open for exciting opportunities and
you have to have band
width in your schedule,
despite how busy you are, you have to have
a little bit of space to be able to take
that meeting that's not
as strategically relevant
to everything on your plate.
So, it is important to
be surrounded by people
that you trust and it's important to spend
your time wisely to
enable you to find that
next opportunity.
- I used to do make up
effects for my stuff.
They were very bad but, I
was the only one doing them.
So, a lot of friends, when
I was doing my short films.
They would see the effect and say,
"Who did that for you?"
And I say, "I did it."
and they started telling
me, "Would you do mine?"
and I started doing it
and I realized it was
an edge with which going to feature films.
And what I did is, for
example, we did a TV series
called La Hora Marcada,
which is terrible film making
but, we were all learning.
Alfonso Cuarón was there, I
was there and Manuel Evescue,
the DP, Guillermo Navarro, my DP.
All of us started in
that series and we were
doing little experiments
and I said to the producers,
"I'll do the make up effects for free,
"you pay the materials,
I do them for free but,
"in exchange I write and I write episodes"
and they said, "That's a good deal."
So, it was a way to put
your foot in the door and
I was already on my way to the Cronus.
I started writing Cronus around 1985 and
I knew that in order to make
the device, the Cronus device
and the make up effects, I
needed to create a company
that would tell the producers
that there's someone
who can do those effects.
So, the sooner I did Cronus,
essentially a year later,
the show was closed because
it had served it's purpose.
- There's a bunch of
cats who, like I get it,
they look at him like, this is stupid.
Why would you waste your
opportunities or something?
They seem to think that this
is something given by others.
Like, they still see it as
like, "You've been given
an opportunity".
No, nobody gave me Jack.
I went and created opportunity for myself.
Nobody ever shows up at
your door, knocks and says,
"Hey man, you want to tell
stories? Here's a bunch of money.
Go make pretend"
That doesn't happen.
You've got to make steps toward that thing
in the first place.
So I spent a lot of time
trying to explain to
people the difference
between given an opportunity
and creating your world.
Creating your own opportunity
because if you create
your own opportunities,
you'll be owing nobody.
And then people can't say things like,
"You shouldn't do this."
I'm like, "Why?"
As long as I keep my budgets low
and everybody gets their
money back and stuff,
I can do whatever goofy
thing I want because,
I'll tell you right now, I
don't want to go to my grave
one day being like, "I should
have made the Walrus movie"
and then drop dead.
I want to be the guy that's
like, "I can't believe
we made that Walrus
movie" and then drop dead
and be satisfied because
then we're talking about
re-shaping the world or
big important issues.
Man, this is all micro not macro stuff.
It all begins, kind of,
with you so, you know,
that's about belief.
You can't expect a bunch
of people out there to
believe you are this thing unless
you be this thing yourself
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video
that you are going to
immediately now apply
to your life or your business somehow.
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a
shout out to TridentLion.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and reading
it and doing a review
on your You Tube channel.
I really, really
appreciate the support and
I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- [Narrator] Today this video
is all about Your One Word.
- Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to be
in yourself and whatever
your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.